Bernie Sanders has been motivated by
radical love his whole life and he has
never wavered this is the same agenda
that motivated dr. Martin Luther King a
year before he was murdered
dr. King and gave a speech in which he
warned us of the three evils facing
America the evils the poverty and the
evil war he launched the people the poor
people's can be building a multi racial
working-class coalition we must believe
and this is why we are here to organize
and that's the only way we can defeat
the dark cloud of hate
[Applause]
well here's the truth and believing that
500,000 Americans should not be forced
into medical bankruptcy every single
year is radical then we're proud in
believing 26 year old Alex from my
hometown should not have died because he
had to ration this insulin it's radical
it believe me that mental health vision
health dental health should be
guaranteed to all Americans is something
that they consider radical then we
should all be held to be radicals
and it's believing that the opiate
crisis is a public health crisis that
can only be defeated by guarantee
Medicare for all Americans and that idea
should be considered radical then how to
be right
[Applause]
you